aquí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y ustedes habrán escuchado hablar acerca
del cdh o trastorno del déficit de
atención con hiperactividad
o tal vez no para los que no saben el
cdh es un trastorno en la atención que
no permite que la persona se mantenga
concentrada por mucho tiempo ya sea en
la escuela en el trabajo o en su vida
social
además al tener hiperactividad provoca
que la persona se mantenga en movimiento
todo el tiempo
yo viví muy de cerca el cdh con un niño
de 5 años el cual la familia empezó a
ver que tenía actitudes raras a
comparación de los demás chicos su edad
sus padres empezaron observando que el
niño se dispersaba cuando jugaba cuando
le hablaba no prestaba atención lo que
le decían y no paraba de moverse
con este niño entró primer grado esto se
intensificó mucho más porque el niño no
copiaba no hacía tareas y no estudiaba
ante esto el colegio le decía a los
padres que el chiquito no le daba la
cabeza y que era mejor que lo cambiasen
de colegio
ante esta presión del colegio de los
padres sin saber qué hacer
decidieron llevarlo a una psicóloga
infantil la cual de diagnóstico déficit
de atención con hiperactividad
imagínense lo que sentían los padres
era tal el sentimiento de no saber qué
hacer para que su hijo se desempeñará
con normalidad que la madre se compró un
libro titulado que le hemos hecho a
freud para tener semejantes hijos fue
tanta la presión que tuvo esta familia
que hizo que la madre tuviera que ir a
el psicólogo para tener una opinión de
qué hacer con su hijo
entre tantas cosas que le dijo la madre
desde niño una de las cosas fue
vos tenés que aceptar que acá para que
tu hijo nunca termine la escuela
esta clasificación hizo que el niño lo
trataran y lo mirarán distinto a los
demás y sentir eso para un niño de esa
edad
en el pasto
cool para esta clasificación el niño
dejó de creer en sí mismo de que él
podía y en cambio lo único que creyó fue
que él era incapaz de todo
y así con este niño lo recomiendo a los
padres que lo llevaron a un neurólogo el
cual plantea una solución que era
medicar al niño con una pastilla que se
llama ritalina la cual según ellos iba a
hacer que el niño se concentrará y
dejara de moverse tanto
lo que realmente hizo está pastilla
según el niño fue que los dos mereció
ilusión sus compañeritos haciendo que
socializará mucho
el niño se dio cuenta que la pastilla
que le daban no le hacía bien
se dio cuenta hasta el punto que dejó de
tomar la pastilla
cuando la madre le dejaba la pastilla
lado la tasa de desayuno él le pegaba
tim casos para que desaparecieran por
ahí
le decía a la madre
que la pastilla no le funcionaba
si estaba sentado pero no estaba
aprendiendo nada
con la pastilla el niño estaba dejando
de ser un problema para los demás solo
eso
este niño tuvo muchísimo apoyo de
familiares amigos profesionales y
algunos profesores que visiona entender
que él no era lo que él creía que era
mucho más que eso
fue tal el apoyo que tuvo este niño que
un día dejó ir a esos psicólogos dejó ir
a esos psicopedagogas a esos neurólogos
y le dijo a la familia que no tomaba la
pastilla y que no la iba a tomar nunca
más
con lo único que se queda este niño fue
con las personas que lo apoyaban y con
la opinión de sí mismo de que él si
podía y nadie le iba a decir lo
contrario
usted estarán preguntando por qué les
cuento esto
porque conmigo se equivocaron si yo he
tenido cinco años yo soy ese niño al que
le decían que no podía
yo soy ese niño y que le decían que
capaz que no terminar la escuela si no
me gusta meterme en la escuela
con cuántos niños más se equivocaron
con cuántos niños más ahora se están
equivocando
cuántos niños más en este preciso
instante están creyendo que son
incapaces
cuantos
sobrepasados y se han acercado para
preguntarme qué te gusta hacer para así
analizar mis capacidades para
potenciarlas y no para hacerle caso lo
que hizo un informe
el sistema educativo esté hecho para
algunos y si bueno estás dentro de esos
algunos vas a ser excluidos y tratado de
incapaz sin antes haber en lo que sos
capaz
el sistema educativo tiene que
replantear una manera de educar que es e
inclusivo para todos pero para esto es
necesario educar al educador sobre el
cdh y otros trastornos
pero no solamente el sistema educativo
tiene que hacer algo para cambiar esto
si nosotros como sociedad no hacemos
nada al respecto qué futuro ustedes
creen que le deparará a aquellos niños
que están y van a estar en el lugar
donde yo salí
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah